good morning everyone and welcome to a
yet another attempt at the app clinic of
video players so before we get started
you know we're going to be reviewing
these these video player apps and
frankly I don't really understand what
the big deal is I mean I've had a look
at the code and as far as I can see this
is all we need to do right we just need
to you know get a video of you put it
somewhere on my screen and then it's
just a simple matter of passing in
different URLs right that's all there is
to it what's the challenge why why are
there why these apps popular why can't
people just you know build it themselves
sure um your ignorance astounds me you
might think that of course it having a
video of you that's so easy to use would
make it very easy to write a video app
absolute this in software things that
are very easy to use are often not very
powerful and that's exactly the way that
video player turned out now we started
way back in the in the early days of
Android with media playback via the
media player API of course that's what
we just saw with essentially a one call
fire-and-forget way of playing back
video a media player is all really easy
to use but it's probably too easy to use
especially if you're looking for
professional custom solutions it's
basically a black box if you have any
kind of special needs you're out of luck
for instance media player is hardware
accelerated but it's hardware
accelerated differently on different
platforms on different versions the OS
and on different OEM devices and there's
no way to find out what type of hardware
acceleration you're getting now that's
not really a problem if you don't want
customization because you're always
guaranteed that an Android device will
playback eight to H dot 264 baseline
profile a lot of people don't like
baseline profile though especially
people who have already encoded for
other devices Chuck so
when we launched honeycomb we decided to
make some improvements and we supported
an API called openmax al now the truth
is openmax al was not necessarily our
first choice because it's not a Java API
but it is a chrono standard much like
OpenGL and allowed us to get some of the
professional features that we were
looking for so if you wanted
professional features in honeycomb and
an Ice Cream Sandwich openmax al is a
great choice the drawback is you've got
to write your code in C hmm with Ice
Cream Sandwich we also introduced a new
way of working with video and that was
the texture view and surface view so
these the ability to actually work with
video textures allowed you to do some
more interesting things like real-time
video effects nice but things didn't
really get real until jelly bean jelly
bean is the apotheosis of video api's by
which I mean we have a Java API that
works nice jelly bean supports what we
call media codec
a media codec is not an easy to use API
by any means but it's a sort of API that
if you are a professional that writes
video apps for a living and understands
media you're going to love it
or at least hate it considerably less
minimizing hate factor that's what we're
all about
absolutely it gives you low-level access
to the media acceleration hardware and
it gives you an API to query what
formats the hardware supports so like I
said it's not a simple API by any means
but it is professional and that it
supports most of the use cases and
corner cases that a really nice video
player needs and we'll see some of those
use cases as we look at the apps for
instance as I mentioned media player
will only Hardware accelerate certain
formats and you don't necessarily know
what formats those are so it's
impossible with media player to make an
application that claims to support every
format or even a large number of forms
and I think you know we noticed that one
of the selling points for the players
that we're looking at today is how many
different media formats they support
absolutely it was one of the biggest
things which most of them claimed was
which media formats they supported
isolating the back and without media
codec you're stuck with two unattractive
choices you can either only support the
baseline formats that are
hardware-accelerated across all Android
devices or you do everything with a
software decoder and don't support
hardware decoding at all right and
that's gonna result in whoops playback
right in general or at the very least
lower battery life because the software
implementation is going to require a lot
more powers that's being done on the CPU
and you know less efficient SSE part of
the SOC there you go that was
educational
so let's talk about if you've decided to
make a media app and it what should it
be absolutely so uh let's have a look so
these are the these are the criteria
which we're looking for the
prescriptions if you will for making a
great video player app and I think we
wanted to break this down into two
general categories I'm sure these are
the main two pieces of functionality
that every video app we looked at has
exactly and you'll note also that we the
apps that we're looking at here a video
player so this is apps where you're
playing back video that you've already
downloaded put onto your device somehow
rather than apps which are designed for
discovering content right so this isn't
Hulu or Netflix this isn't a Google Play
or a streaming service this is all about
you've gotten video you know from your
camcorder or you downloaded it from one
of these sources and you want to take a
look at it exactly so there's the two
categories of browsing and playback so
for browse it's really about easy
organization it's about being able to
discover the information that you've
already got on your device so if you've
got one or two videos then that should
be fairly straightforward but you've got
to think in terms of scale what if
they've got you know tens or hundreds of
videos that you want to be able to
browse through what's that experience
like we sort of went through a lot
this with audio absolutely backups when
we we talked about those about a month
ago and how one thing that can make or
break an app is how easy it is to
discover the content that you want to
play and ignore the content that you
don't and one of the most important
things that a video app can do in the
Browse mode is respect the no media file
that a lot of game developers for
instance will download a bunch of ad
eyes or MPEG fours to a media directory
so that they can play it later on in the
game now because that's not a
universally accessible global media
directory that's meant to be played by
anyone they'll stick a dot no media file
inside that directory and if you don't
respect that you need a lot of nice
oh absolutely you're going to get
cutscenes from games that you didn't
even know existed a lot of times they
don't have very informative names shell
ends up being kind of a spoiler really
don't know what that is until it's the
end scene from a game that you have with
your playing yep so thanks a lot bard
steel is ruined for me in terms of
playback is kind of what you'd expect
and again what we've sort of described
already in terms of why you're building
these apps to begin with and it's the
ability to be able to playback pretty
much anything so I don't want to have to
think about what the codecs are how is
being transcoded I just want to copy
stuff onto the device and have a
playback and I wanted to do it
efficiently as well so hardware decoding
where possible absolutely I also want to
have my app support subtitles oh this is
really important for hearing-impaired
people to me it's important because I
like to watch foreign language films my
wife does not speak English as a forum
or as a first language you have some
problems with American I believe right
oh that's alright it can get confusing
absolutely so you need to have those
subtitles just in case absolutely and
and the last thing we wanted to talk
about was the notification bar or status
bar being the real one and we saw a lot
of apps trying to sort of half take our
advice here and say oh well people say
that they want to have their status bar
visible because I want to see what the
time is they want to see you know that
sort of information battery life Wi-Fi
connectivity
of course they weren't taking our advice
I mean these are features of these apps
it's not just a long time it's obvious
that people want to be able to see the
sorts of things that they see in a
notification of our battery life and the
clock being two very important ones
absolutely but if you're going to show
that already why not just support all of
the use cases when I have a notification
I want to be able to pull it down I want
to know if if I need to stop watching my
video because there's an important
meeting that I completely forgot about
it
absolutely so let's have a look at the
apps which we're going to check out
today so the ill poor app developers for
these apps have been waiting for two or
three weeks now for this feedback but
we're gonna be looking at MX player CNX
player and dice player so three video
playing apps there so let's get started
I guess let's let's kick off with it the
first step we wanted to look at was
Synnex player and as you can see we've
got the they've got a feature graphic
which is really nice yeah and the
feature graphic here is nicely done but
I I wouldn't I wouldn't use this one
personally yeah I mean you can see we're
looking at confidence monitors from a
fair distance away and you can't really
read the name of the app from here it
fades into the background the contrast
isn't really high enough and the words
are too small now all I see is X with
maybe an E and something that's either
an R or an X next to it yeah who can say
so that you know they've they've got the
table stakes here they've got the
ability to be featured or promoted in
Google Play by having a feature graphic
which is really important but they
haven't taken advantage of and we've
seen just recently people blogging and
talking about the fact that just having
a better feature graphic you can have a
significant impact on your downloads
should you be fortunate enough to be
promoted exactly I can guarantee that
for this one they wouldn't even run it
this would get kicked back to the
developer just because it's illegible at
those that does dimensions absolutely
well why don't you show me what's next
player does absolutely we've got our
fancy HDMI setup does not work today and
the reason is that most video apps do
not actually just
lay the UI out of the HDMI port so
instead what we've got is a even fancier
and far more expensive solution I'm a
andis high tech home movie camera it
pointed at the screen here so we're go
ahead and see how that works
today sort of camera you'd expect to
same seeing the movie super right only
probably the ones filming the movie
separate rather than the featured in the
movie super exactly so so this is cnxn
so see next play so you can see straight
away as we've opened it up we've got a
really customized display at least you
can see part of it with the with the
reflection but that kind of makes the
point in that it is it is a very dark
looking display mm-hmm I'm not gonna
complain actually it's fine one of my
complaints about the other apps is that
they're too white yes and part of but
but the big deal here is that it is
entirely grain we've got these massive
areas here for thumbnails which aren't
populated which is a little bit
surprising presuming that this that
these movies can be played back it's
kind of weird that you wouldn't display
the thing that really confused me is it
felt like we had a thumbnail area but
there is no thumbnail anywhere I mean
nice even on you know camcorder videos
and and stuff that I completely expected
to have a thumbnail the things that even
had a thumbnail in the gallery yeah are
not shown with the thumbnails I did they
just run out of time to say it's
disappointing though because I mean this
is a video playing app is very visual
that's kind of the point and so part of
creating that immersive experience is to
have the thumbnails here so that you're
immediately drawn into washing one of
these things really about all of these
assets about engagement and then liking
here I think we're you know we don't
want to spend too much more time on this
black screen so why don't we what do we
go ahead and play this week in Android
development oh I can't be done
disappointing so it's nice that they
give you the ability to report it but
disappointing that it's not able to
playback what seems to be a reasonably
standard encoded and P for being the the
end before that you pirate it off of
YouTube yes bit you know well I like to
think of it as the mp4 that I uploaded
to YouTube rather than the one
down from right now I just noticed that
my my microphone here has fallen off and
so probably need a lot of dialogue help
in post nice change everybody like I was
too loud today so uh so let's close this
then so it does give you the ability to
report which presumably will give them
the ability to get feedback on what
encoding types they don't support but we
can go back here and click on on this
other video and have that playback right
and so right away we can see as we
disappear here we've kind of got
partially immersive but but not really I
mean its thumbnail but that's fine
because it is a very small very low
resolution yeah yeah well this is this
ducking cover it is can we get it to
there you go so if we can blow it up so
you can have at the native resolution
will blow it up to full which is nice
and we go fullscreen but we don't really
go fullscreen no yeah you can't see on
the display that the navigation along
the bottom is still visible it could be
as is the the standard notification so
my it kind of feels like my status bar
should have gone away and if this was
running on a phone I can tell you that
it would that the status bar would have
disappeared but because this isn't
targeting tablet devices or isn't
targeting Android 11 we have the menu
button mmm it's kind of shameful and
what it's doing here but it's not a
standard menu button of shame well I can
tell you that not targeting andr 11 is
is actually the main problem with this
app Android technology as we just
learned has moved on considerably from
the old Gingerbread Froyo days where we
didn't have a particularly good
system-wide story for video and now
we've got so much better api's the
hardware has has come along considerably
the framework now supports a much not
only much better video playback but also
much more interesting UI organization
it's shame that senex player isn't up
with the times in that way
absolutely so again so the big thing
here which would be nice to see so
they've actually implemented this sue
a notification bar along the top here
which does have CFA pause that'll stop
it so it does have the time and it has
the battery life as well so it's trying
to give us the the sort of information
which would normally be in my
notification bar but frankly I just want
my notification bar back and in this
instance it's not even getting rid of it
so it's it's sort of redundant a few
other things which you know which I
wanted to mention while we're looking at
CN ex-player the Menu button which I
already mentioned this should be
bringing up a menu ideally as part of an
action bar overflow menu and what you're
looking at here is really settings which
should live behind a settings dialog
what you can see at the bottom here
which is really nice is that they have
used the audio effects API in Android
which is allowing you to modify things
like treble bass 3d effect and bass
boost which is all part of the Android
meteor effects framework which is really
nice feature for them to build in that
is cool alright
well I think that that that gives us a
good idea of what's in X player is about
let's go ahead and go on to our next
victim so I think the next oh well
before before we do move on there is one
one thing I wanted to mention which is
if you look at the at the market listing
or the Google Play listing for this app
they mentioned that they require the
phone state permission to be able to
listen for when you've got incoming
calls presumably to pause playback and
do sensible things now as it happens
that's probably overthinking it so
Android does already give you a way to
be able to know when things like that
happen most basic of which is it'll
pause your activity right so yeah when
that happens it's probably a good time
to just pause and put everything you
know I'm a better note here I've noticed
that this is in my opinion what
separates the more professional
developers from the less professional
developers I don't know I think you and
I have discussed before or both readers
every now and then we technically take a
look at the website called the daily WTF
absolutely and it seems like 90% of the
WTF moments on that site come from a
developer finding some convoluted way to
get the result they want and not asking
gee
is there a better way to do this like
instead of writing 200 lines of date and
time parsing code in Java wouldn't you
want to use the date/time class and
wouldn't a a wise developer think to
themselves
I wonder if such a thing as a date/time
class exists it reminds me of my
graphics class one of my first graphics
class at college where we were giving
given a task to to draw a circle mm-hmm
on a canvas and and so we all
disappeared into the lab and after a few
moments most of us had the ha moment
when our canvas dot draw circle that was
not enough to dissuade some of our more
intrepid folks who had all the arc sines
and cosines and were building the whole
thing through a series of loops and it's
like that's very impressive entirely a
waste of time admirable but yes that's
unless you're unless you're doing this
from the ground up on 1980s era hardware
there is probably an accelerated routine
in there that you would never be able to
write on your own because you don't have
access to those particular parts of the
framework those particular parts of the
hardware yeah and and this is a good
example of that if you if you find
yourself in place where you need to make
the Android device do something or you
need to do something in response to what
the Android device is doing and you find
yourself writing convoluted code that
asks what is the user doing or am I on a
tablet so I know whether to rotate into
mordor or landscape or you're just doing
a lot of queries chances are this is not
always true but there's a high
likelihood that you're going to be able
to find something some event that you
can just catch in the android framework
and if if for some reason that doesn't
suffice if you found a place where let's
say on pause does not give you the
information you need to pause then
that's a bug and that's really important
and we will we definitely listen to that
with interest in terms of audio playback
in fact there is a one additional step
you can take which is listen for the
loss of audio focus so you may find that
you know while you're watching a movie
that you have some other audio app
starts playing
you want to be able to pause when that
happens you can listen to the listen for
loss of audio focus and pause your
playback at the same time and there is
in fact an Android training class called
managing audio playback which will give
you all of the information you need to
do exactly that read that class because
even apps which correctly catch audio
focus change messages have done some
some horrible horrible things what was
the one we were just looking at an app
which actually in response to audio
focus change started playing something a
zero volume stream that was muted oh
that's helpful
yeah and for some reason I don't know
the whole story but after playing that
app nothing else would play on the
entire whole system interesting because
it never gave back audio focus exactly I
just decided to play a zipper volume
file that's that's impressive yes so the
next app which we wanted to look at is
MX player now this is an app that I
think you looked at in more detail but
I've in fact I used this one a little
bit myself so we're both a little bit
familiar yeah I think we we both ended
up really enjoying the playback
functionality of although I was a little
disappointed in the browsing
functionality now you don't have quite
as much on your device as I did um but
you it starts out with this really
simple browsing interface now
unfortunately it has something that
looks like an action bar but it doesn't
really act like an action bar there's
there's no navigation there's no
importance so when I move down into this
movies folder for instance although I
get pretty much what you did to that
announcing there's no way for me to move
up and there's no real indication that
I've moved into a different location in
the hierarchy now once I had several
different folders and playlists and
alternate locations on my device I found
that to be sort of disorienting yeah
absolutely
I didn't really like not knowing where I
was in the in the general hierarchy of
my device it might just be me well I
think it's it's an interesting point and
something consistent between all of
these apps which is that the browsing
experience doesn't seem optimised for
content discovery so I can see
these apps have probably come from is
people who have this content and they
wanted to view it on their tablets the
native media played and do the job and
so they've built apps to do that so
knowing what's on there and having it
already in a directory structure and you
know all chances is probably going to be
enough for them to understand but as
you're trying to build something for
more people to use who didn't build the
app you really need to make things like
navigation much more prominent so people
who didn't design the app still
understand how it was I feel like the in
this case the navigation is working like
it certainly does the job but it doesn't
show the sort of craft that we've come
to expect out of the top Android apps
and that's sad because the playback
screen yeah this is where really really
shines all right so I'm going to resume
watching so we can Android development
the playback is great immediately comes
full screen when I decide to bring up
the UI it gives me not only a nice a
nicer you I know it's a little less
obtrusive but it also lets me know for
instance am I read the code and lets me
choose it does have you know we we
didn't see all this on the on the tablet
but on the phone I believe it does
actually bring up the real notification
bar that will indeed and you can see
that by if we hit play here it will no
it doesn't it does okay so you can see
everything's disappeared and in fact
even the navigation here so it's using
the the Android 4.0 you know low profile
stuff and on a phone it will do exactly
that so it gives you this completely
immersive experience no notifications no
clocks nothing as soon as you hit the
screen boom you get it all back you get
the status bar you get the action bar
you get the status of navigation the
whole thing and I like that it keeps the
UI up when I'm paused right absolutely
it has a very nice scrubbing
functionality here very nice it also has
some gestures which I think are really
interesting the moving left to right in
the middle of the screen will scrub a
little bit more sensitivity
and then on one side of the screen you
get brightness nice and then on the
other side you get volume very nice so
that's a cool innovation no definitely I
like that um but what I found most
valuable of all yeah because I have an
eighteen-month at home 18-month year old
girl she absolutely loves to watch
videos of her mommy and of herself and
not of me but no he comply but it drives
her nuts drive me nuts when the video
goes away because she pressed the wrong
area of the screen she doesn't know
anything about soft buttons or the back
button the home here the app switcher so
just knowing that mommy went away and
she doesn't know why so one innovation
that I thought was really really
interesting here is this child mode
where you press I'm gonna go ahead and
and bring it out again while you're
playing back you can press this little
lock button and that puts you into
lockout mode so anything you do on the
screen will have no effect except for
pressing as a prying along with them
right so interesting it doesn't
completely solve the 18 month old
problem but it does mean that she's much
less likely to hit that tiny little
button correctly then if you the little
fingers yeah well that's Hannah Senter
requires a bit of a long prostitution so
it's been difficult for her
did you know how they how they went
about implementing not I have no idea I
have absolutely no idea how they did it
or whether the way they did it is
considered kosher in any way the same in
silage in even if it is very usefully
looking forward to having a conversation
with the framework team and with the
developers and see how they went about
it absolutely because although I think
it breaks a lot of Android rules on the
other hand it's kind of useful oh that's
always an interesting challenge so in
general this this app scores big on two
counts first is that it's got a really
nice UI and second it doesn't ream
move you from the normal Android
experience so as you as you go out of
the full screen mode you still have the
normal Android action bar and the
notification bar everything that you
want the only thing I said action bar
but I meant notification bar but
speaking of action in the browser that
really should be a real action bar yeah
absolutely
now why isn't it a real action bar well
probably because we haven't released a
compatible action bar exactly that seems
like a all the reasonable tenant and
many of the things that they're doing
can't be supported in anything below
jelly bean hmm so it would be nice I
think well they don't have a
particularly complex browser which is
one of the known of the comments that we
had and so it would seem like the work
involved to get a real action bar give
that native feel for the more advanced
devices would be worthwhile an
investment at this point so just one
last note on this browser and I think we
could make this comment about a lot of
apps is that this sort of little
thumbnail on the left side of a ListView
with gigantic amounts of white space
around it is really getting old and some
of the newer apps that we've been very
impressed by lately and not doing well
in the in the Google Play Store have
gone to a completely different tiled
view with large thumbnail so the title
is overlaid on an alpha blended
background so you don't have any white
space at all I've seen and I think that
ends up being a much more pleasant
browsing oh absolutely and again you
know just you've got this wonderfully
immersive video playback experience it
would be wonderful to have that as part
of the browsing experience as well and
really make this much more like a
gallery frankly a lot more like the way
that the YouTube app works and then you
open it up and you kind of get this wall
of video now that's obviously very
specific to YouTube but it's that sort
of feel of trying to immerse you in
content which makes you feel all the
more willing and and desirous of being
able to just start playing stuff back
you know see what's behind each of those
windows at the same time let's face it
we're gonna spend 2 percent of our time
browsing in 98 percent of our time
watching absolutely definitely delivers
the goods when it comes to watching now
nearly
is good in that department is our next
app dice player but I think before we
talk about that we wanted to discuss a
few more coding was indeed so one of the
things which I really liked about MX
player was the fact that it handled that
immersive experience correctly right so
we got rid of all of my chrome but then
brought it all back as soon as I press
the button and so if you're wondering
how do I do that well here's the code
that tells you so for Android 4 and
above what you want to do is actually
set the system visibility options to
system UI flag hide navigation so what
that will do will actually remove all of
the chrome the status bar the navigation
the notification bar everything on
Android 4 devices and you'll note that
at the same time as we set that flag
we're also going to set a listener which
is going to set the UI flag either
visible or fullscreen so that's going to
remove your notification bar on phone
devices as opposed to tablets so this is
the neatest way and that's what we're
seeing on this device if you go back
before that on Android 3 so honeycomb
devices it's a little bit different we
have we have the ability to hide the
status bar and we also have the ability
to go into what's kind of a low a low
profile mode and so this is going to
eliminate your status by your
notification bar on phone devices and
it's going to make your navigation on
honeycomb devices be those three little
dots so it hides as much as a can but
doesn't actually give you any extra
screen real estate right this is what we
used to call lights-out mode exactly
like that mode so that's kind of your
next best for sort of fear honeycomb
IRRI devices if you go back one step
further before we had tablet devices and
the only Chrome that you had on the
screen at all was the status bar the way
to do that was to flag fullscreen you
know set the window layout parameters to
flag fullscreen and that will remove
your notification bar and this is
something which is only appropriate to
do in a very specific circumstances and
playing back video is one of those
circumstances and the important thing to
note here for pre honeycomb devices is
that you have to manually add it and
remove it and so one of the temptations
that I've seen a lot of apps do is they
simply remove it and you never get it
back so even while you're browsing when
you
not even doing video playback you still
don't have your notifications it's
infuriating so what you actually want to
do here is tie this code into play and
pause of your of your media so whenever
you're playing you can hide the
notifications and as soon as your pause
you bring it back again so shall we move
on dice player I think was the the next
app that we wanted to take a look at so
this doesn't have a feature graphic so
it doesn't have the table stakes to be
featured even if we wanted to which is
disappointing so that should be the
first action item for those guys
indeed yeah we're very disappointed to
see that but dice player in in its
implementation actually quite nice
actually I think that they've got the
best browser mmm of the ones that I've
looked at I suddenly looks from here
very similar to MX play but with a real
action bot which gives it the end you
know the very similar to the MX player
meme will sort of resurface as we as we
go through this but yeah it's your
typical browser as we said could be
better but the really nice thing is that
as I go through the browsing experience
I have a very predictable and familiar
action bar layout an action bar UI
pattern to deal with so I can navigate
through the action bar navigation
pattern and I've got also my actions
over here now there is one thing that I
confuses me a little bit there's a
screen for well you know what I'm gonna
let you guess this is this this little
thing that looks to me like a monopoly
house what did you say that that button
will do I'll say I would have assumed
that that was a misplaced home button
effectively have navigate you do that
well what you would expect when you're
hitting this button here sort of taking
you to the to the route navigation to
but see what happens when instead it a
complete surprise mediate full so this
is how you manage which local folders
and oh it even looks like remote sources
are being indexed fully your video right
so I kind of felt like I did when I
bought my first box of wonka mix-ups
yeah Andy where all the colors are wrong
and the strawberry one is orange colored
and the grape one is purple no grape
would be now
anyway the point is I felt mixed up the
what this actually took us to is a
settings page for getting other types of
media now in this defense this is an
awesome piece of functionality I can
choose a Samba server I can choose an
FTP server I can take an HTTP stream
very nice and add them all into this so
if you if you're like me and you've got
like a lot of videos on a share on your
Windows machine and Linux machine at
home then being able to connect to solve
our FTP is a really nice piece of
functionality and I solutely I did test
this with my Windows machine at home and
it screamed a large video directly off
that machine and that made me super
happy absolutely but the functionality I
don't think I ever would have found if I
hadn't been thinking well T how do I get
to the home screen of it yeah well
indeed and we're kind of a special case
because you know we are reviewing this
apps we're gonna hit pretty much every
button to see what it does a lot of
users are gonna even be looking for that
particular functionality take one look
at the app go well no I can't see it
anywhere in Cal said anywhere here I
guess I guess it doesn't do that all
right
and then move on to the next step so
make sure that any particularly useful
function I like this differentiating
functionalities is really easy to
discover and while we're talking about
discovery 2 this is something I noticed
a lot with the settings a lot of times I
found apps that have really really
intriguing functionality and it's hidden
in a piece of the settings sometimes
that I wouldn't even even thought to
look for show and in some cases its
functionality that I really really
wanted that sort of wish was either
turned on by default or perhaps just
more discoverability because there's
some really cool stuff in here that I
wouldn't have thought to look for
now when it comes to playback there's a
couple of things that I really really
like about this application now I've
been using MX player more and I think
you have to yeah and there's really only
one reason for that and that's because
MX player doesn't hide my notification I
mean in every single other way yeah dice
player is superior in its playback UI it
supports essentially the same scrubbing
motions as we saw before including the
the fine-tuned scrub here
right but it's not doing a real time
frame for viewing we do right I'm I
trace back the in every other way I was
I was exaggerating there I was overly
excited I'm countably so to play excited
it's a problem but in nearly every way I
mean it they and and they do have a lot
of the same than in yo over here we go
brightness over here we've got volume I
see they've swish that around from him
explain well you got to be different
absolutely and I think MX player
actually patented the right hand that
could be it so you can see actually as
well well we do have the playback
they've again sort of half gotten right
the the immersive experience and so you
can see you probably can't see on the
video but when there is playing back
rather than losing the navigation
completely they go into a honeycomb
compatible lights-out mode and so
they're sort of up to date up to
honeycomb but haven't taken at that
extra step for jellybean right and so
that makes it useful on tablets because
I do get my notification bar backs right
but on the phone you don't that seeks
out on a phone instead you get a sort of
fake notification bar that has the time
and has the battery indicator yeah but
it doesn't show me any of my
notifications which is something that I
generally like I also don't like the way
that the UI just goes away when I'm
paused I don't refer that it remain
other than that though it does have of
course the child lock mode that we saw
before one thing that I really like is
that it automatically selects to be
hardware accelerated
yes the hardware supports it and if the
video is
coated and way that the hardware can
decode so I don't have to do what I did
on the other app which is think okay
this really should be hardware
accelerated yeah no I didn't play with
it enough to see if it feels on any
particular videos or even if I'm an MX
player will actually remember defaults
that would be cool too but on the
initial you know first blush I think
that this at is a little bit better at
playing back video I would like to see
scrubbing that will be nice yeah that
would be really just the little visual
touches which I think MX player have
done a good job on absolutely but this
has some really interesting features for
instance it does have the capability to
speed up videos which is great on your
more recent this week in Android
development since you you bowed to all
the pressure yes well all those non
English speakers who said they couldn't
understand you little do they know that
when I spoke at a more reasonable pace
they still couldn't understand me not at
all
no this way I don't have an excuse
exactly so the other thing that I think
is just incredibly interesting here I'm
not gonna say not gonna say too much
about it let's let's just see what it
does I press this button here oh my
goodness look at that how interesting I
I'm not sure whether it elaborated but I
I get the feeling that if I were using
my tablet for a lot of let's say email
wrote tasks I might really appreciate
having a video that I could just play
back in the corner
it certainly appeals to me for the couch
potato scenario where I'd like to have
something playing while I browse for
something else yeah yeah I know no we're
gonna make of this I'm pretty sure I
would know what the framework team would
make it I am pretty sure they're doing
something sketchy that's good Rick yeah
I wouldn't windy banking on this one
there there will be sorrow at some point
but it's it's an interesting feature
it's certainly taking things in a
direction which I don't think anyone
else is thought to do so a fair play for
that it's very interesting and and I
think that as I've shown this to my
friends the the people that I've shown
it to who
our die-hard Android let's say actual
developers on the framework team yeah
think that it's a little sketchy other
people they actually think it's kind of
Awesome so yeah yeah you know that'll
happen
absolutely absolutely yeah you know
people like to Crystal Pepsi to you
people like can you cook vegan how are
we all right so let's have a look we
don't want to spend too much more time
today this was supposed to be a shorter
episode and we seem to be completely
unable to mitigate our own blab amounts
but let's see if we can have a look at
some of the prescription I think these
absolutely I think we're by the way
we're we're 20 minutes behind time and
that doesn't even count the five minutes
that we spent jerking off at the
beginning of the show
that's very true that's very true now
aren't you glad that we're not doing
this live and we can cut that a hug very
glad very glad let's talk about our our
results from this week's app clinic
indeed so this is the prescriptions for
cine ex-player
so the big thing there was to use the
audio focus and onpause
to control the playback rather than
relying on notifications from the system
that incoming calls are happening in
those sorts of things we really think
that they should revisit their custom UI
nothing wrong with the custom UI
particularly for an app like this which
is very immersive but I think they're
almost an action bar but isn't an action
bar that includes a search control that
isn't a search control is probably
something that they might want to
reconsider and the same with the custom
status bar you know really take the
advice and handle full screen in the way
that you know tablet and phone users
have come to expect that ability to be
able to hide everything and then bring
it back as soon as you're playing things
I also wanted to point out that the
Google Play listing for cine X player
has a fantastic testimonial saying how
wonderful the app is on an iPhone now
that's not entirely good right I mean I
don't think it bothers us but it bothers
our merchandising team right so if
you're building up like this and you
want to be featured and frankly who
doesn't you may want to consider things
like that there is going to be someone
on Google Play merchandising team who's
going to look at these apps and if it
doesn't have a feature graphic they're
going to pass it by if it's calling out
compared
is probably gonna think twice as well so
prescriptions for MX player are
considerably shorter because we both
love the app it was a nice app yeah but
we'd really like to see a better action
bar yeah it seems like such an easy win
you know they're already using all of
the native Android 4.0 stuff they've got
an action bar or something very much
like it in the view put it in the
browser as well and gives that that
experience that we used to absolutely
but the video playback I think in
general was really was really great and
the only thing that was jarring was that
I would go from the video playback which
is a dark theme and usually a high
contrast experience with with the videos
that I watched and then I would be
plopped directly into this light themed
browser and especially at night you know
if I'm watching videos in bed or
whatever that was a little bit jarring
it I feel like maybe a dark theme is a
better choice for some of these apps
yeah it seems like it would make sense I
did want to call out as well with MX
player one of the things that they do
really well is this ability to play
pretty much anything we threw at it and
we threw some pretty obscure media
codecs at it and was able to decode
everything if not always at full speed
at least it was able to figure it out
which is really impressive it's
absolutely true I remember we threw a
QuickTime animation play video at it and
it didn't choke each other surprisingly
played it very slowly but then again so
did my Mac
exactly right it also passed the test it
was the only app that we looked at which
was able to play back media which we
plugged into the device in any way so
whether that was native on the device
via an SD card or even via a USB key fob
which I managed to dig out of a skeleton
well not skeleton but cobweb.the strewn
corner and we're still able to do that
so that's that was impressive a DOS
player did a lot of things right most
importantly I think it got its defaults
right mm-hmm
if a video could be hardware accelerated
it was I think you were pointing out if
the video was very small it
automatically fools screened it which
none of the other players did I was
surprised and you can argue either way
you can say that they should be showing
it to you in its native resolution first
and foremost but really if you're
looking at these apps at these
these videos I should say on a tablet or
on a phone chances are you just want it
to be fullscreen you just want to enjoy
it as immersive experience as possible
so it kind of makes sense to default
that way so really there we just had
some NIT so we really liked the the nice
player playback engine and the way that
it handled defaults correctly but we
really hated the way that it hid the
notification bar hmm
and this is nitpicky but we felt like
the action bar could use a little bit of
work when I hit the back button it
popped up a confirm to exit dialogue but
I don't even know why you do know I
excite I mean this confirmed two exits
is one of my pet peeves along with exit
buttons and exit menu items there really
isn't any need for it there's no need to
confirm to exit just make sure that
there is no status lost when they exit
you know you get the on pause you get
the on stop record shared preference it
says what movie they're watching what
the current playback position is and
then if the app gets killed while you're
in the background well that's fine when
you load up load it a lot for you know
I've worked with a lot of video games
that were really really concerned about
what happens when you accident but
that's because they're building these
gigantic OpenGL structures and they're
loading lots of textures but with this
really you're recording where you're at
in the video and maybe you know a zoom
level and volume and brightness and a
few other settings that's it
because resurrecting the video playback
engine on Android is a very very quick
task they've probably reticulating any
splines exactly so get rid of that get
rid of the custom status bar during
playback we've really rather just see
the normal notification bar and in that
is it looks like really all these guys
need to do is take another look at at
the jellybean API is because they're up
to date the honeycomb but I haven't
quite nailed it and I think they have a
look at code samples we've given here
and take a look at the new jellybean
api's for this then they'll be good to
go exactly so we've already shown how to
handle fullscreen correctly if they take
that to heart I think the
a much better user experience absolutely
so that's that's the end of the app
clinic for today very special midweek
episode of the app clinic to hopefully
make up for our terrible terrible
disasters in the last couple of weeks we
are going to tempt fate this week by
doing to our clinics we're going to be
back on Friday to do an app clinic on
shopping apps which we thought was going
to be about apps like Amazon or Zappos
but then we realized a module on Zappos
are the same company and there are go
there shopping which is apparently what
all of our viewers thought as well so
what we have is shopping assistance apps
so we've learned that people would like
us to review shopping assistance apps
and that we need to be a lot more clear
when we say what our app themes are each
week indeed but we do have some news in
that area I won't spoil it today but
when you tune in next time we're going
to be talking a little bit more about
app themes and what will happen to the
apps after we've reviewed them over very
exciting absolutely so well yeah it's
it's been it's been an interesting
experience we've gradually increased
things and so you'll see that or in fact
you may have already watched Nick Roman
and Adam doing a UX makeover on a couple
of these apps and so we're gonna try and
find more interesting ways of being able
to take the apps that we look at and
give them a more thorough going-over
exactly well thank you to everyone who
nominated apps for our video playback
app Athan indeed we really enjoyed it I
found some apps that I didn't know about
before and thank you again for everybody
who nominated shopping apps now what are
we gonna do after shopping apps I think
there was some talk of celebrating
Halloween with Halloween Halloween apps
what is a Halloween app reto my well I'm
new to this country so I assume that
there are a huge amount of apps designed
specifically for Halloween how to carve
a jack-o'-lantern
how to keep track of the candy that you
receive and give out surely there is a
huge huge pile of apps that that people
will have designed specifically for this
most sacred of all holiday seasons I can
only hope you're right and if that's not
the case what are we going to do instead
oh hi that's a very good question now we
probably have a look at whatever the
next category we have and see if there
are people
nominated absent that absolutely now you
did put up a set of cards on that one
site that you like so much
trailer that's right yes so we will
share I once again the link to Trello on
that on Android developers plus page and
for those of you who thought like me we
were mistaken it is not actually a
Russian guy singing in a weird singsong
voice or is it no way to know until you
sign it indeed all right well thank you
very much for viewing yet another
episode of the app clinic we will be
back Friday with more and don't forget
to watch on Tuesday when Roman Nurik
brings us his version of Android design
in action thanks for watching I'm right
in my eye me Andy Lewis see you later
Cheers